Cool.
Hello, everyone.
Hey.
Good morning.
Thanks for coming here.
It's probably been a long week.
The last couple of days
have been crazy here,
and the traffic's
not been fun either.
So hopefully it's been
working all well for you guys.
Some of you have made your
way from a different parts
of the country, many
different areas.
But I hope it's been worth it.
And there's a lot of interesting
things that we've been doing.
So we want to talk a little
bit about some of them.
You've heard our keynotes and
the great products we have,
et cetera.
Today I'm going to talk a little
bit about machine learning,
right?
The title says machine
learning is not
the future, which
is kind of weird
given that we're talking about
machine learning in everything
we're doing here.
But the point that I
wanted to bring across here
is it's not really the future.
It's part of everything
we have today
as you're seeing without
products as all the things
that we're talking about.
We're using machine
learning today
in everything we're doing.
And I want to talk
about some of that
and tell you how
you can do that too.
But first, let's start
with this all started.
So and this goes back to 1997.
I don't know how many of
you remember this Tik-Tok
from "The Wizard of Oz."
He's one of the early versions
of robots in modern times,
really.
Although there are references
to automatons going back
to the 5th Century
B.C. And stuff,
even the Egyptians and
others way back when.
But in the modern
times, this is probably
one of the earliest
references to something
that was close to a robot.
Any of you familiar
with Tik-Tok?
How many of you are
familiar with Tik-Tok?
Not too many.
Let me tell you a
little bit about him.
So this one is-- in
fact, the term robot
wasn't even coined
back when Tik-Tok
was created by Frank Baum.
And what this robot would do
is it had a winding thing.
And you needed to
wind the robot.
And it would run.
And it could do pretty much
what a human could do but not
really be alive.
And it was a great
reference to things
that we've always wanted to do.
And so a lot of
this AI and robotics
and a lot of these things have
been part of science fiction
for a very, very long time.
In fact, a lot of what
we do today in science
has been driven by people,
literally authors, et cetera,
are able to really build
up and think about what
the future might be like.
This is one example, but
there are many, many more.
For example, if some of
you have read Asimov,
he has a bunch of books.
And he has this whole
robotics cities,
again way back in the '30s
where he talks about robots
and how they might
be like and the kind
of things that come with it.
And that was very interesting.
A lot of people
over the years have
been inspired by these science
fiction books and movies
to do a lot of
interesting things.
Another example of that
is back in the '70s
from "The Hitchhikers
Guide to the Galaxy"
there is this robot
called Marvin,
which is this depressed--
it's always depressing.
He's always talking about these
things he's not happy about.
He's just too smart for all
the things happening it.
And it's really a
great example of what
people have been
thinking about what's
going to happen in the future.
And now going to
another example,
"Star Trek," another thing.
The example that I
put here, you can
go to Data in "Star Trek"
who talks about-- this
is a poem he composes, which
I thought was pretty funny,
and how people have
been thinking about AIs
and what they would
do and what they
would be doing in the future.
In this case, again,
it's like a robot,
like a humanoid, somebody
who can do a lot of things,
but is not quite human.
Then coming to more recent
times, more closer to 2001,
if you've seen Steven
Spielberg's movie "AI" called
"AI" itself, they have
these mechanical robots
that can really do-- that
look like humans, that
can do all kinds of things.
But they don't feel.
And then they build
this little kid David,
who can actually feel
and love as well,
and really changes
how the perception is
and how they think about
AI or what it means
to the people around them.
And then much more
recently there's
this movie called
"Her" in 2013, which
talks about AI without the
shape, without the robotics,
and all of that.
But AI is just that live
within your computer as an OS,
essentially, that can
interact with you.
That's your assistant,
but much more than that.
It actually feels as well.
It understands
things, et cetera.
So all these are great.
There are so many
different things
that people have
been talking about,
people have been thinking about.
But these are still
science fiction.
This is not really what machine
learning is about today.
This has always been the future.
It's still the future.
Maybe at some point
it will be a reality.
But that's not
where we are today.
That's not what
we're talking about.
But there are some real
things that we can do today.
And those are some of
the things that I'm
going to talk about today.
So we've actually made
over the last few years
real progress in terms of all
the different things that we
can do with AI with
machine learning,
use all the products
that you see around you.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit about those.
There's so much
in there that has
benefited from machine learning
from what we call AI as well.
And so this is some of the
smallest of products, really,
at Google that we made that used
machine learning in some ways.
But at Google, anytime
we think of a product
there's, of course, programming.
And you build it, and you do
all sorts of things with it.
But machine learning is an
integral part of everything
we do in building that, because
we want these products to be
really smart to give
you the right things,
to not just follow your
actions, but really
give you the right things when
you want them as you want them.
And I'll go over some examples
of these in later slides
as well.
So before I go
into other things,
let's just go a little bit
into what deep learning
and machine learning is about.
And I'm just quickly going
to give you some examples
on a website that we have.
So part of this slide is going
to talk about TensorFlow.
And recently we put
the site up called
playground.tensorflow.org
that allows
you to play with neural nets
that allows you to really do
different kinds of things, and
allows you to really understand
how these networks work,
how machine learning works,
and be able to play with
some of those problems.
So I'm going to start with
a very, very basic problem
classification.
The goal in this case is there
are two kinds of clients.
I just want to classify
that it's ARB, in this case
the orange or the blue ones.
And I'm going to use
the very simplest case.
It's a very simple
linear classification,
if any of you guys
know what that is.
But the idea is you
have some inputs.
In this case, the x-axis
and the y-axis are inputs.
And based on those
two inputs you
want to decide if it's a
blue one or an orange one.
And so what this model
is going to learn
is some parameters
to figure out-- OK.
If I get some point, I get the
an x1 value and a x2 value,
how do I decide that?
It's some mathematical
computation
that it needs to do.
So in this case, it
does that iteratively.
Let's just quickly run this.
I've just set it up
as a linear model.
So lets just run it very quick.
And as you see here, its
looking at x1 and x2.
And very, very
quickly it figures out
how to separate those out.
It just draw a
line in the middle.
And its just optimizing
what that line looks
like, how to separate
these out very simply.
So this was a very easy problem.
This is typically not how
the real problems are,
but it's a great place to start.
So let's go to a slightly
more complex problem now.
So let's go to
this one here where
you still have those
two kinds of points,
but now they're
clustered differently.
So there's one in the
center-- is a circle,
and the rest are around it.
So can we actually solve this
using the same kind of methods?
Can we actually classify
using the same thing?
If I run this, do you
think it would work?
Any guesses?
Let's try it out.
So it's trying to
separate this out.
It's basically trying
to draw a line.
But it's lost.
It's really not
making a progress
if you see what's
happening here.
So there are a few things
you can do about this.
One, in terms of
classification, again,
going a little bit into machine
learning into the details,
you can add more features, more
kinds of things about the input
data that helped
the model understand
or how to separate them.
So if you guys remember your
math back from high school
or college, in this
particular case,
given how these
clusters are structured,
if you looked at a
couple more features
from based on the inputs,
like in this case,
x1 squared and x2
squared, you can probably
use those to separate
this out better.
So let's try this.
Let's add these two
and see what happens.
And taking those
two values, now it
knows how to separate
those and clearly
separate it out into two
separate, different classes.
So this works.
This great great, right?
This is what happens
or used to happen
in machine learning very
often for every single thing
that you do.
If you take a bunch of inputs,
you want to solve some problem.
It's typically the
inputs themselves
that are not in the
same kind of mode
that you need to
solve the problem.
And what you do is
called feature generation
where you are
combining or crossing
those features in different ways
to really solve your problem.
But there's a lot
of work you need
to do in figuring out the
right features that make sense.
In this case, it was
a simple problem.
So we knew x squared, x1 squared
or x2 squared would work.
But in some cases, the
problem is not as simple
and you really need to
do a little bit more.
So for those kind
of cases, we have
something called
deep learning which
seems to work really well.
So let's go to go
back to this example
and let's see if we can solve
it in a different way as well.
So let's take out these
two features first.
Let's change this linear
to a nonlinearity.
In this case, I'm going to
pick correctify linear unit.
And I'm going to add a hidden
layer with a few more neurons.
So what this is doing is
it has some inputs, as we
said in this case just x1 x2.
I'm adding another
layer, which is basically
trying to combine those
inputs in whatever
way is interesting to solve
our particular problem.
And then let's see if we can
train this to actually solve
the same problem as well.
So if you see this, we took
the same features, no feature
generation.
We just added one layer.
And this is a simple
problem, so one layer works.
And it's very easily able
to separate those out.
This is essentially what deep
learning is doing for you.
As you add more layers, it
can understand and learn
the right layers
of abstraction that
are the most interesting to
solve your current problem.
And of course, it
depends on the problem.
It doesn't have to be a
simple classification.
It could be regression.
It could be recommendation,
whatever you are trying to do,
really.
You can apply similar
techniques to do that.
So let's go back to our slides.
In a sense, deep
learning's basically
the same machine learning
ideas with more layers
there that allow you to get
different kinds of abstraction.
Of course, as part of that you
get many, many more parameters.
You learn things differently.
This example is
actually for what
we call inception retreat, which
is our state of the art image
model for image classification.
So And we'll go through some
examples of how we use it.
But this basically
gives you something
nearer human accuracy.
So machine learning has
been around for a long time,
in fact way more than 10 years.
What's really
changed since then?
One of them is more
compute, definitely.
Over the years, our
computers have gotten faster.
We have more of them.
We've been using newer chips,
CPUs, GPUs, now 2PUs here.
And so a lot of things
that we're doing here--
and more computer allows
us to really build
more complex models,
more bigger models.
But that needs a
lot of other things
to go with it as well for
that to work, in this case,
better algorithms and
more data help as well.
So over the years we've
improved the algorithms slowly.
A lot of these algorithms that
we talk about in deep learning
are 30, 40, 50 years old.
But over the last
10 years, we've
seen some improvements
in the right places.
For example, in a
case of deep learning,
there are some improvements
to back propagation
or the kind of nonlinearities
that we use that really make it
much easier to optimize those.
It used to be
really, really hard
to train some of these models,
even if you had the compute.
Even if you had the data.
Now it's much easier and
there are better techniques
to do that.
So the math and the
algorithms is improved.
And of course, the amount
of data that we have,
that keeps growing.
And that really is something
that machine learning can help.
If you think about it with
small amounts of data humans
are great.
You can maybe read
10 pages of a book
and understand that
and sift it down.
But what if you had
a million pages?
You can't really expect a human
to go through those million
pages, understand those,
and summarize it for you.
You really need some machines
that can automatically
do this for you.
And that's really where
machine learning comes in.
So now let's talk a
little bit about what's
happening in research
in machine learning now.
We've talked a little bit
about science-fiction,
mentioned a bunch of
products that are using this.
And I'll go a little bit
more into the products later.
But let's talk a little bit
about the research, where this
is going, some of
the examples of where
things of made improvements
in the recent past.
So the first one I want
to talk about is AlphaGo.
How many of you of
heard of AlphaGo?
Wow, quite a few.
So if you remember actually
almost 20 years ago now,
there was deep blue, which
is a similar chess computer.
In some sense it was similar
that the goal was, OK.
Can we really beat
the best humans,
Casper of the reigning champion
in that time using computers?
And back in 1997
was the first time
Deep Blue, which is this
computer built by IBM
that actually beat
the world champion,
beat Kasparov in a full
championship match.
That was pretty amazing.
And that was 20 years ago.
It took a long time to
go from there to Go,
partly because Go
itself as a game is
way more complex than chess is.
The possibilities that you have
at every level at every step
are much, much bigger, much
more than what chess is.
And so one of the
differences there
is with Deep Blue
you could get away
with some smarts and
a lot of brute force.
You could have a
large supercomputer.
You have some basic smarts and
a lot of rules around-- there
are a lot of chess
players there that
actually taught Deep Blue in
the sense it would train them
on-- OK.
Here the good moves.
Here are not, et
cetera, et cetera,
plus allowing it to do
a lot of brute force
in trying out-- OK, looking
ahead how many different
moves you can do.
Now those same
techniques just could not
work for Go because of the
different possibilities
at every step.
At every step we can do a
really large number of moves,
and supporting that or being
able to go past a few steps
is extremely hard, even
for modern day computers.
So what really
worked in this case
was a combination of
smartness and the computer.
And in case of
smartness, they applied
deep learning to figure out, OK,
looking at a board, what kind
of moves make the most sense?
And then let's try them out
and see what makes sense
and which ones of
these play well.
And so it's a combination of
improved algorithms, improved
machine learning, combined
with the compute power as well.
Another example
is ImageNet, which
is this data set of a
million images with 1,000
classes of different kinds.
In fact, a lot of
classes are so close
together that it's
very hard even
for humans who don't know
about them to identify
without learning.
For example, there are
breeds of dogs which look
very similar, at least to me.
For people who really know
dogs, of course, it's easier.
Over the last few years,
over the last five years,
especially on this
data set, this
as really driven the state
of, well, vision understanding
for machines is.
So about five years
ago, the accuracy
that computers would
get was maybe 70%, 75%.
This was the measured top five
accuracy, which is basically
is the most-- the correct answer
among the top five results
that the computer predicts?
Now, five years ago this
was something like 75%.
Today it's past.
It's over 96%, which is
considered to be better
than human accuracy.
Humans also make mistakes
in this kind of thing.
So it's really coming a
long way and just shows
the kind of progress we can
make if we really get down
to improving machine learning.
This one's an interesting one,
taking the kind of image models
that we've trained and
really letting them dream.
This is what we call Deep Dream.
There are some
folks at Google who
basically took
those new networks
and wanted to understand what's
happening in these networks.
What are they learning right?
And so in this
case, what they did
was took a few neurons
in the network,
just let them train
from that point
and try to see what
we can generate
from those neurons, what
they might be understanding
from the images.
And so they converged
to some of these.
So in some of these
images in the top right,
it's basically started from
some kind of palace or whatever
and combined those, and
[INAUDIBLE] of that.
The one in the top left it
has some fountains in there
and a bunch of other things
that sort of combined.
And this is very interesting
because in some ways
there are similarities to
what people do as well.
Of course, this is a
very different view.
But it's starting to
learn in many, many ways.
Machine learning is really
doing the same kind of learning
that people might do.
So now I'm going to
give you some examples.
Let me just go to this and
play some, a couple more
videos for you.
In this case, it's doing what--
it's basically taking the video
and applying different
kinds of painting styles.
In this particular one it's just
picking a blue painting style
and applying it to the
existing video in real time.
Now it's a charcoal sketch.
This is just an
example of how we're
mixing machine learning
with things like art
to all kinds of
interesting things in
and interesting
combinations things that you
can do with these.
Here's another one where it
makes it look like a newspaper.
So this one's based
on a paper based on
by Justin Johnson and
others here at Sanford.
Let me give you another
example of similar things
that we can do.
So this one is interesting
where the network
learned from a bunch
of Chinese characters.
It looked at how
they're drawn, and was
able to really draw completely
new Chinese characters I've
never seen before.
These aren't real
characters, actually,
for those of you who
understand the script.
I don't, but then
they look very real.
Even for people who
understand the script or who
know the script, they feel
like they're almost there,
they're clearly not the
right character or anything
that they've ever seen.
But it's very understanding
what's happening there.
It gets tagged it's
supposed to look like this
and is able to understand
that whole domain as well.
I'm going to show you
a couple more videos.
Here's one where it's basically
learned from a lot of numbers.
These are house numbers
from Street View.
Let's just go back here and
play it and pause it at the end.
And so it's learned a bunch of--
it's looked at house numbers
from Street View and is able
to really generate those.
It's actually never seen
these particular numbers.
The network is generating them.
This is the kind of things that
these networks can do today.
And the last one, in this case,
it's actually generating faces.
And so, again, it learned
from a large face data set
and now is able to generate
faces in all kinds of ways.
Again, these are not faces
that's seen directly.
It's regenerating them based
on all it's understanding
of what faces look like.
Yeah.
Another one that we've
actually released very recently
is this model to
parse sentences.
So this is a very semantic
parsing of sentences
where it looks at a sentence.
In this case, I booked
a ticket to Google,
and tries to understand
what the subjects are,
all the grammatical
stuff about that,
actually things that I
personally don't understand,
and it's hard for me to learn.
But this is able
to actually learn
from a lot of sentences
that were given to it.
In this example, it's actually
making the sentence piece
by piece, and then building
a tree of hierarchy,
and doing the
parsing in this case.
This kind of thing
is extremely useful
when you're trying to
understand natural language.
And this just goes to show
how much these computers can
understand the language that
you and I speak in some cases
better than humans can as well
or at least better than kids
can.
Here's another example, sort of
going back to the data example
where in science fiction
this-- here's this sort of poem
that a computer might generate.
This is actually something that
was generated by a real program
today or a real model today.
It's clearly not great, but
in this particular case,
it just learned from
a bunch of books.
It read those books or
understood those books.
And was able to generate
this particular poem.
So now let's talk about
this grateful research.
Now let's talk
about a few products
and how we're using them.
So we had this
slide early on where
I showed you a bunch of products
that [INAUDIBLE] using this.
Let's go into some
of those products.
Let's see how we are
actually using them.
What are the kind of things
we're doing with machine
learning in these products?
First a search--
I'm sure most of you
have-- or probably all
of you have used search
or are using search
in some ways.
This is a very good example of
how machine learning is used.
The slide that I
showed you here,
there are at least
two ways we are
using machine learning here.
The first, if you
use Y Searcher--
so if you click that icon
on the right for the mic
and you say something,
there's machine
learning being used to
understand what you're saying
and converting it to text.
So you say something.
That's really a bunch of
bytes for the computer.
To convert that into
actual English or whatever,
like you're speaking, it
needs to understand that.
And there are pretty
sophisticated machine
learning models that
do that for you today.
Then the next part
is once you have
that, what results to show you?
Google has billions or trillions
of pages really indexed,
which you probably
don't even think about.
What you see typically
when you do that search
is just 10 pages
on that first page.
And you really
want those 10 pages
to be the best ones, the most
appropriate ones for you.
In some cases, you might
go to the next page or so.
But most people are just going
to look at that first page
and make their decision.
So how do we really take
those billions of pages,
match them to your
query, and then even then
it's probably millions
or maybe more,
and then put them down to
those, whittle them down
to those top 10 pages?
And that's, again,
machine learning
at work in many, many forms.
We're taking all these pages,
understanding your query,
matching it through all
the data that we have.
Maybe if you're looking for a
restaurant near Mountain View,
we're going to leverage
that and understand
that that needs to be combined
with the kind of pages
that are there.
If it's something else,
again, understanding
the query and the documents
together, combining them,
and then ranking them,
and sorting them,
that something that machine
learning does really,
really well.
This example is of pictures.
We talked about vision models.
They're actually used in
everything you do now.
So for example, over the years,
image collections, the amount
of photos I have are huge.
They're just growing.
With digital cameras
coming on, it's
been so much easier to
take pictures and just
keep collecting them.
You never throw them away.
But then when you
want to find a picture
and you really want to go
through those collections,
it's really, really hard.
So how can you do that?
In this case, the
same kind of research
that I was talking about,
which understands those images,
is really indexing and
labeling all the pictures
you have in Google Photos.
And in this particular
example, if you
search for cherry
blossom, it really
shows you all your art
pictures of cherry blossom,
and can display them for you.
Another example is email.
So there is this thing
called Smart Reply, which
we launched a few
months ago, which
you might be using in email.
And what happens there
is you get an email.
You typically, in this
case, you probably
just want to get a
quick, easy answer.
And it just gives
you some choices.
Here, pick this one.
And what it's doing
is it's really
understanding what your
email thread is about
and then suggesting a bunch
of replies ranking them
whatever makes the
most sense and showing
them the most interesting
ones to you if it makes sense.
Another one is Google Music.
There are many things
happening in there.
And one of the things that we do
is we recommend a lot of things
that you might want to
play, maybe albums that you
might want to play,
maybe actual songs
that you might want to
play based on the time,
based on what you are
trying to do right now,
based on your interest.
It's really understanding
all of that, sorting them,
and, again, ranking
them, recommending
the right things for you.
We only want to make it easy
for you to find what you want.
The ideal case would
be you go there.
Let's say it's
afternoon or let's
say you're driving
back from work.
And you typically like to
listen to, say, classical songs
at that time.
It should really
just recommend you
the classical song and
maybe the top station
that you do every time.
You shouldn't have to look
for it just because-- just
before this, you were
doing something else.
So all of these are examples.
Machine learning can
really make a difference
and are helping us in
our everyday lives.
And one more that I'm going
to talk about is spam.
So everybody uses email.
A few years ago,
many 5, 10 years ago,
spam was this huge
issue for everyone
where most of the
emailing in our inbox
is starting to be spam.
You have to actually
filter them out manually.
So it's not that from that
time on to now spam is reduced.
In fact, spam
continues to increase.
It's just there are
filters, and algorithms
have gotten a lot better
at recognizing what's spam.
Again, they're not perfect.
Occasionally you'll
still see spam.
Or maybe we would say something
is spam when it's not.
But they're getting
so much better,
that I don't go to
my spam for spam box
and see what I
might have missed,
or the other way around.
I rarely get emails
that's actually spam,
even though if you actually read
the numbers about how much spam
emails there are,
these are still
way more, maybe 10 times more
than the real emails of spam
itself.
So lots of improvements
in machine learning,
lots of improvements
in the products
that are driven by
machine learning.
So it's not about the algorithms
or the technology itself.
It's about how do we apply it
to the products that we build?
How do we make things
better for all the things
that we're trying to do?
All of this technology,
and algorithms
in the computer
that we're building,
it's all towards
solving real problems,
solving real needs for
things that we do today.
So now let's talk a little
bit about TensorFlow.
That's the product I need.
And it was built to help push
machine learning forward.
Our team is a research team.
And part of the goal for
us was to really push
machine learning forward.
And that's why we built it.
But that's not the angle, right?
We want to take that
machine learning as well
and apply it like I was saying
in all of these products.
TensorFlow allows us to do
that, and now you as well.
And I'm going to tell you
of how we can do this.
So it is open source.
It's a machine learning
lab available on GitHub.
It's, in fact, the
most popular machine
learning library we opened
source six months ago.
And it's rapidly
going to the top.
There's a lot of interest.
There are a lot of people
using it in all kinds of areas.
Some of the research that
I talked about, actually
people outside Google who've
taken up TensorFlow, and used
it in doing a lot of those--
building those new things
and new ideas, people
are including it
in different kinds
of products as well.
So at the core, it's a library
that's-- let's go a step
forward.
So what's this library
for right there?
There are many different
things that we can do.
Like I was saying, our group
is doing a lot of research.
So it is for researchers who
want to take machine learning
and really push it forward,
make it much better than it is,
improve the algorithms, improve
how we can do things with it.
So it is for them.
But then there are
data scientists
who want to really take
those algorithms-- let's
see our data, let's
see our product.
And you want to
improve that product
by playing this machine learning
to the data that you have.
And so the data scientists
can take those algorithms
because they're also open now.
They're made available to
you on all kinds of places.
You can take those.
You can use those and
make some improvements.
And then there are
developers, like a lot of us
here, actually, who are
trying to make, say, an app,
and want to make it better,
or say, apply a product
to their data center.
And TensorFlow allows you
to really take all the work
that researchers and data
scientists have done,
and really run those
same models, the train
models in production using the
exact same APIs without having
to worry about-- OK.
This seems great,
but how am I going
to deploy this to production.
That's another complexity
that that's harder.
So we definitely try to make
sure that from the beginning,
from the point that you get
started in machine learning,
to actually pushing
it out, to production,
it's a very short time cycle.
You shouldn't be stuck
because of infrastructure.
That's taken care of you.
That's taken care of for you.
And you can focus on
what's important for you
in the most ways, which is
really building the products,
helping your customers,
helping your users.
So just a couple examples
of TensorFlow-- not going
to go too detailed
into the code,
but this is a very simple
example where we just
take two inputs, do
a matrix multiply,
and just print out the
result. So what it's doing
is in the first two
cases, it's creating
two nodes in the graph.
And actually, let
me just-- yeah.
It's creating two
nodes in the graph,
and really doing a
multiplication, which
is another node, which takes
the inputs from the other two
nodes.
And then the last
one really evaluates
based on the two
inputs, combines them,
and generates the output.
This one's actually
a regression problem.
So we talked about
classification earlier.
In this case, it's trying to
predict some values based on,
can we have some inputs?
Can we have some outputs?
You want to learn to
predict the outputs.
It's basically doing something
similar to what we were seeing
on the playground where
you're taking inputs,
you're multiplying by matrix,
and you haven't lost it.
You're trying to
optimize it, which
is a typical machine
learning thing.
And then you just loop through.
So the last, at the end,
you basically have these.
You're going through a bunch
of steps, and say 200 times
in this particular case,
and you just print this out.
And over time you're
basically learning
to predict things better.
Again, very simplistic
examples, typical models
might be much bigger.
But in a lot of
cases, you might also
be able to use models
that are already there.
Why don't we just
give you some examples
of the kind of performance
we provide comparing it
to some standard benchmarks
that are there on an open source
website.
And early on when we
launched TensorFlow,
it was in the fastest
library out there.
And there were a lot of
improvements that we had to do.
But over the last six months,
we've really focused on that.
And in this point,
it's really at the top
in terms of compare compatible
to everything else out there.
And we continue to improve it.
There's not the end of it.
There are many more
improvements that you can do.
In this case, we're combating
four different kinds of models.
In this case, they happen
to be all image models.
And as you see, the
load is actually better.
In a few cases, it's
just slightly worse.
In few cases it's
slight-- in one case
it's likely better, and so on.
So it's roughly about the
same ballpark performance
at this point.
Now, one thing you can do
with TensorFlow as well
is you can run it across
many, many machines
rather then running
on just one machine.
So the previous benchmark
that I was showing you
was basically running
on a single GPU
and training these
models on GPUs, something
that a lot of people do.
In this particular case, we're
training on many, many more
machines, so each machine
having a single GPU
going all the way to 100.
And you can see it
scales quite well.
In fact, up to 16
it's almost linear.
And then it's still going to be
used to scale you in past that.
And this is something that
we use internally as well
to train really large models
and large data sets, which
is-- as the data is going,
it's really important to be
able to do this, to be able
to run on clusters, which many
of you probably do already.
Oops.
So next I'm going to talk a
little bit about TensorFlow
for Poets.
So there's actually
a code lot for this
as well if you want to look
at it and look at it online,
or I believe there's
a place here too.
So the idea here is-- let's
say you have a bunch of images,
in this case
flowers, and you want
to learn to recognize
those flowers,
or maybe you just
identify if it's a flower
or if these are five
different kinds of flowers.
And what you can do
is you don't have
to have a million examples.
You might just have
1,000 examples, lets say.
But you can get started from
a model that works really,
really well.
For example, our
best image model
that you've open sourced
and made available,
and that's what this
example talks about.
Take the top part of
it, just train that
on your data set from the point
that it's already trained on.
So it's just going to learn
to classify the flowers.
It already understands
image well,
so it doesn't have to really
know what kind of features
are important for
classifying images.
It knows that already.
It can just take your particular
models, your particular data,
and learn to just separate those
out into different classes.
So there are a few
tools that I would
like to mention at the end
that you can play with,
or that you can use before
you go in terms of just making
things work well for you.
So a lot of you are probably
familiar with Apache Spark,
which is used for doing
analysis and doing
learning on large data sets.
So there is an
integration of Spark
with TensorFlow--
somebody at Databricks
did that-- where you can
actually take some images.
You can create.
It's very simplistic
in the sense
you can create a lot
of different models
and really use it to
pick the best model.
You do that a lot because there
are some having parameters
like, say, learning rate or
how big should your model be,
et cetera.
You maybe try 10
different models and use
that to pick the best one.
Another thing I would
like to point you do
is Google's own Cloud
Machine Learning Platform.
We announced this a
couple of months ago.
It's under limited preview
right now, but you can sign up,
and we will make it
accessible to you
soon, where you can really have
the same power of TensorFlow
that you have on
your machine say,
but maybe don't have
the compute resources,
or you don't want to manage
all the resources that you need
to really run at large scale.
And cloud takes care
of all of that for you.
So you can experiment
on your machine,
make sure you understand
what you want to do, and then
push it off to the
cloud, let it take care
of running large scale stuff.
There are a few
examples of what you
can do with models that have
already been trained by others
and really take them
and just apply them.
There are some APIs
on the forum today
for what's called the
Mobile Mission APIs, which
allows you to do face tracking.
So let's say your pictures,
it allows you to-- it
identifies parts of the faces.
It first identifies
the face, and then
parts of the face like
the eyes, nose, et cetera,
so you can do different
kinds of things with it.
It also recognizes
barcodes and QR codes
and automatically understands
and parses them for you.
On the cloud there are also
some APIs for vision and speech
in translation, which you can
basically just send your image,
and it tells you
what kind of image
it is among a lot of
different classes.
For speech, again, you can
upload data, upload speech,
and it will give you back
text for whatever kind.
For translation, you can
give it text in one language,
say English or Japanese or
whatever makes sense for you,
and it's going to convert
that to another language.
So many different APIs,
and this is a growing area
that you are going to
need to watch out for.
So now for the future.
It is really.
I started by saying it's really
not the future, but it is.
It i the present and the future.
I just wanted to call out
that it's important for you
to start thinking about it now
and not wait for the future,
really.
And it's really
your turn to start
thinking about how you can
incorporate machine learning
into everything that you do.
What people are
looking for today
is not just applications
that do what they want.
There are tons of things
that are already doing that.
How can you add that edge?
How can you how you make it
really better for that user?
By understanding what
they want before they
ask for every single thing.
And that's really
something that you can do.
Think about this as you
build your next application,
as you build your next project.
And I think that's how
we'll change the future.
That's how we'll make machine
learning part of the future.
So I wanted to leave you with
some place with some pointers
to where you can read
more about TensorFlow.
It's on GitHub, and their
docs are tensorflow.org.
And going back to my
reference for Tik-Tok,
Tik-Tok is waiting for you
to really make the difference
to do these things now.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]